- he did me that favor hey welcome
everybody to the h3 podcast thank you do
privacy and Teddy fresh for sponsoring
us today Whitney Cummings is here with
us the incredible comedian actor
producer writer am I missing anything
no philanthropist podcaster now
podcasters and I and I have here even it
says and now podcaster oh yeah she's the
host of the brand-new good-for-you
podcast the incredible Whitney Cummings
thank you for being here thank you
what's uh what taken us so long to do
that I know it's I'm really happy and
we've done I don't know why we don't
have that many female guests and it
really bothers me why is that I don't
know no do not do they come to you or to
someone ask or how does it work it works
both ways
uh-huh but I just I don't know why that
is but I'm glad that's that do you think
all the talk about poop and I think we
have a male audience but that doesn't
matter we transcend that yeah I think so
that's really interesting I I don't
really know how it's an I'm just getting
into this how podcasts get found and
shared you know word of mouth and I
don't know who knows okay well here we
go here we are in every way possible
just me there's nothing you can do
we're done how is it that you're just
getting into podcasting now what what's
inspired you I have to be honest I know
I might not give off this vibe I think a
lot of people think I'm very confident
and self-assured but I'm actually pretty
shy despite how I pretend I'm not you
don't look you don't think I'm shy yes
from you media I follow you on Instagram
from like what I project is from why
yeah right from the photos it really
Malone in my home when no one's around
because I'm isolated well sometimes you
you'll post videos and you just have
that like confidence it looks
I am really confident with no one's
around okay judge me or give me feedback
i I think I am confident when I'm on
stage doing stand-up that's where I feel
safest and where I can take risks and
where I feel good about myself but
podcasting I think for some reason
because I was like well is it jokes only
like I know how to be I know how to be
confident when I'm telling jokes but I
can just never felt like I didn't have
the self esteem and I think I'd be
interesting enough to like talking to
hours interest you know so I just I
never I was like who would want to hear
me talk for two hours and then I did a
bunch of other people's podcast and I
was like oh these people I could do it
yeah and then I learned a lot of people
aren't tuning in for people to be funny
all the time right true and also you
what you learn is that the bar is very
low and nobody expects anything from
podcasts it's interesting also you don't
really like to be in you don't need to
be that interesting kind of like I don't
know how you think about what is
interesting I mean I'm sure you actually
do have a lot of interesting things
going on with like your comedy career
and the help you do with dogs whatever
you know people just kinda wanna hear
about your day yeah exactly so for me I
always just thought like having me like
television and stand-up you're like you
have to be interesting and funny every
word has to matter and everything has to
be a perfect joke so I was like it takes
eight months to make an hour of stand-up
it's fit to be shot for television so I
was just like two hours a week like this
is exhausting and then you know Joey
Diaz was like they just want the wiretap
they kind of just want to hear you
having conversations and being authentic
and then I'm like oh wait now I have to
figure out how to be authentic you know
I find I think a lot of the comedian's
that have podcasts which are a lot of
them now yeah once you get the rhythm of
just kind of talking and rattling stuff
off and stream-of-consciousness you I
feel like a lot of them end up like
developing content or material from
medium it kind of becomes like a little
think tank like incubator where you
served are talking about something
you're like oh that actually could be a
great joke and yeah I think it'll be
interesting for people to now watch you
know specials and then listen to
podcasts and hear how to get started
kind of developing
in contrast it is good to see that
personal side of people though because
comedians to have this kind of they have
an air about them of their on the stage
and they're so confident and touchable
but you there they're not so human up
there but the podcast strips that away
yeah I mean you know for the most part
be you know being on stage it's a trauma
response you know it's some kind of
self-protection mechanism you know like
most comedians offstage were not that
funny and I think I didn't do a lot of
podcasts that weren't comedian podcast
for the longest time because I felt like
I had to go on and be really funny and
only comics kind of know we get together
more like how we get to be born together
thank God but then I felt like when I
went on other people's podcast I had to
like try and be funny and I'm like I'm
just like bombing at 10 a.m. you know so
I just like wasn't really going on
podcast like could I now I kind of get
it that's good you know and you're like
um sorry and also I would say that in
the TV and movie business is imploding
so I figured why not yeah I wasted so
much time and energy like dealing with
like the [ __ ] politics of television
I was like wait you can just make
something and not get notes from a guy
that went to law school that's right it
knows nothing about comedy like I don't
have to have some volume fixed you old
married guys tell me I'm not likeable
you will get notes in the form of
YouTube comments oh that's right but you
don't have to or it's I mean at least
it's not someone that gets to decide no
faith and I could also maybe delete them
I don't know how to comment or you can
ban wouldn't do that out really and I
only did that with Instagram comments I
did is to just not look and just let it
be and just forget that it's there
because if you have if you believe the
good you have to believe the bad yeah
that's right and I don't even believe
the good yeah I really magnify negative
comments it's like it's like we have
comedian brain like if you're performing
for 5,000 people and one person's not
laughing that's the only person I'll
think of I feel like I just was also
thinking about podcasting and comedians
I feel like it kind of starting to
influence the style of stand-up and
interests
owpain I think you're right it's true I
think you're exactly right because I
feel like there's kind of like a style
that is going out of fashion like jokes
and very setup and very structured
that's really really interesting and I
had not thought about that till now that
everyone's becoming a little more
conversation and a little more
vulnerable we're now - I think I'm thick
in the way yeah if we're in a situation
if you're doing a stand-up special and
you don't admit a secret about yourself
no one gives a [ __ ] yeah true you know
like Marin and you know all these shows
where you go on and you'd be vulnerable
and you talk about your childhood and
stuff like that and then people go see a
stand-up set where you're just like
Facebook jokes airplane jokes
everyone's like aren't you gonna tell us
about that time you got molested your
parents drop the ball she does I think
that's all he wins it's actually kind of
the worst thing for the other people
that have been molested that now they
have an inferiority complex about their
molestation because Bobby's was so good
what was it he got he got a dude with
Down syndrome put a thumb up his ass as
far as molestation stories go he takes
the cake let me ask you this yes sir in
our previous episode we do episodes
without guests actually most of our
episodes are without guests yeah and we
venture into you know it's dicey
territory into the fields okay for
example here's one and tell me what you
think Zak our sound guy we've been
talking about the use of bidets I'm new
to be using bidet uh-huh so you got
money now yeah that's new money [ __ ]
yeah
do you i briefed people every days
because himself yes because I got
complaints from people in like Southeast
Asia those hazard I guess
yeah I mean are you be there no don't
like it well the people you know I
Metamucil or I don't go and try I just
go and [ __ ] [ __ ]
wipe move on call today it's not a mess
you must have bling I really do I'm
actually what's in here
here is something called athletic this
is duty this is my [ __ ] I can honey
badger I never know what I'm enough to
step out so and it helps with all of
that but I'm I'm really yeah I don't
really mean and I do a lot of veg and
things things move pretty well we do so
and vegetarian last week you went where
we're vegetarian oh cool good for you
yeah awesome my poops have been pretty
good I'm not gonna lie how many times a
day oh no it's not that serious once or
twice you're supposed to shoot three
times a day I believe I don't I feel
like I have been since we're like
officially vegetarian yeah think I'm
still pooping once a day yeah twice
maybe have you ever taken a lo pills I'm
about to blow your mind and your [ __ ]
colon yeah
aloe pills it's if you ever get
constipated this is the best thing in
the world to take like if I'm flying a
lot and I'm dehydrated or I'm just
eating trash on the road you know
because this is like Brad on the road
like Airport but it's just like so many
chemicals and [ __ ] it stops you up
dehydrated taking a low pill you will
[ __ ] it's just a [ __ ] pill it's a [ __ ]
pill basically but you will [ __ ] like
liquid even when you think you're done
it just starts clean well we carry
around like they say about five pounds
of [ __ ] at all times
that's kind of just like congealed to
our which is a lot of the reason we
don't absorb all the nutrients we need
right when we're tired a lot so it just
will blow out your you're just giving
yourself an enema I do it like twice a
year
Oh cuz I'm like not in great shape I'm
gonna know better after unbelievable I
believe yes well 10 pounds lighter
emotionally and physically Wow I've
never done that
I've never cleared my bowels to such an
enormous degree it's just it's just
helpful to know how much [ __ ] you're
carrying around oh I'm like this [ __ ]
just keeps coming out wild but since I
haven't eaten meat and the amount of
plant-based stuff I eat I feel like I'm
in pretty good shape
well what I was gonna say is that my
zach and back I mean a debate about the
bidet he says that he squirts that the
[ __ ] and then he's not inside not
like a it's not a colonic you mean just
you know how bidets were
yeah it's like a power wash on your okay
[ __ ] yes yeah a pressure wash yeah
and so he takes soap and then he soaps
out his [ __ ] mm-hmm and then he
leaves the soap in the bowl and the
bidet bowl and I thought that was the
craziest thing I ever heard
you see you can't flush up a day no no
it's like a sink I have before like put
my butt in the tub and wash my butt was
it that bad I just don't I don't see the
time like I ride horses like I do soul
cycle like stuff like that if there's a
time where I feel like I've gotten a
little swampy and I just need yeah it's
not like I have [ __ ] everywhere it's
just more like I just feel like I'm a
little gnarly yeah because a shouter a
shouter and then I've got a thing in my
bathtub that's like you know a sprayer
wash thing and I'm just gonna
antibacterial soap and I'll just go I
don't have time for a shower but I do
feel like this crevice in particular I
see I feel like that's different I
respect that
I feel like that's different no because
you just have a swampy ass like when
you're when you do a wipe you do a bidet
you're ready to go about your day and
then you soap your [ __ ] you're
touching your [ __ ] and you leaving
the soap in the bowl that disturbed but
I don't understand why you'd leave in
the bowl why wouldn't you just flush it
you it's not a [ __ ] it's like a sink
that you sit on okay and then where does
that water go it just goes down the
drink so you [ __ ]
uh-huh like your ass I don't you go over
to the bidet like a sink yeah yep yeah
and so he leaves but you know but
throwing this over to you Zach we had a
lot of people who were trashing me for
my my response to Zach's story but it
just seems to me that you've already why
touch your [ __ ] now right but there's
soap on your hands protecting your hand
from your ass thank you you're welcome
why do you need your [ __ ] so clean no
it's because I do think that how bad
[ __ ] smell I think sometimes you're
like how are my
nor in pants all that's protecting
everyone from this you know what I mean
it's like psychological you know back in
the day before they had underwear they
used to actually get like diseases from
farts really like if you don't cover a
fart then the [ __ ] particles are
airborne yeah of course which is pretty
which is pretty cool
yes
what's your ideal [ __ ] process then well
this one is have just moved and we can't
use baby wipes I was a baby wipe
I'm Paula cuz you can't flush the baby
wipes no good no good we can put the
trash can
yeah you want to die on them so that's
my team I got scared of [ __ ] I do not
like I mean I first I wipe with toilet
paper like the really gross part yeah
you you go for the hazmat toilet paper
and you flushed that back then I do why
see here's where me and you are kind of
in a different realm of existence
because my first wipes are are like
Chernobyl the back 5 to 10 are still
like whoa whoa what was the name of the
Japanese a reactor the Calcasieu yeah my
the back five or fukuko okay this is now
this is starting to make sense to me why
are your [ __ ] so [ __ ] leaders as I'm
foolish I'm I know I don't do that as
I'm European Jew what do you eat I think
if you're well I like some salsa and
like Mexican I don't when I wipe my [ __ ]
that there's hardly anything on it what
a missile no because since I've taken
made a missile I'm like that some people
have clean sheets
she just [ __ ] your sheets are not clean
doesn't see my people don't I don't know
what to say I'm a big gnarly guy I like
to eat vegetables I like him yeah well
you do eat salads actually hate salads I
like fruit hmm me and I but I used to
eat a lot of me taking digestive enzymes
is that like uh do you mean like flamin
hot cheetos just like help
digest the food a little bit I think if
your shits weren't so viscous maybe the
wiping wouldn't be such a song yeah you
like this guy like the word yeah we
don't like this now yeah I think we need
to get your shit's more solid I went
vegetarian but I think the bidet is
great it really is yeah how do you dry
it with a towel but the shit's gone
though you wiped your ass with a towel
that's hanging not my ass sorry this is
what I meant at all not my [ __ ] just
my thighs cuz they get wet from the
bidet and I just wiped off my thighs so
how do you try your [ __ ]
it's a little done it sounds like that's
what breeds bacteria you don't want to
keep your [ __ ] damn well nobody's
eating out my [ __ ]
you know that's probably why well I'll
take know but if somebody everybody
wants nobody's eating out ass [ __ ]
anyway I don't care there's nothing good
about know what okay you wash your ass
in a bidet I ask you pocket and it looks
like them to and left and right yeah and
then you only dry your thighs off
because it's not that's where the
majority of the water is so it's a
little it's a little wet but so then you
just put boxers over your wet butthole
yes and then your shorts and then does
your [ __ ] get cold like not cool what
if they're wise how old so you just feel
comfortable being cold before sometimes
everything off so how do you warm your
[ __ ] I don't know yours is wet all
the time it's just one tear also I have
insulation still a lot how long does it
take for it to dry like a couple minutes
it's not a big bill uh-huh why wouldn't
you just dry it with a towel cuz I don't
wanna put towel
then hang it next to me why wouldn't you
just what about washcloths since you
only [ __ ] one way today just yes dry it
because what gets rid of the smell is
getting rid of the bacteria did a doctor
so I did learn this [ __ ] I have made one
good decision in my life and it's full
that's the dead skin cells that make it
stink you want me to scrub my ass I want
you to scrub your [ __ ] with a
washcloth and then put it in the no I
it's funny my [ __ ] fine I'm bringing
this up talk about we spent 50% of the
show talking about my [ __ ]
ok so I'm walking into a hornet's nest
here know what you do with the tower
wait just put in dirty clothes I'm not I
hate shits drinks i decant I thirst like
just watched it yeah but what is a
little bit someone else is gonna have to
touch that okay don't you pay them yeah
I think she stopped wearing gloves what
[ __ ] I mean this is did you guys not
grow up with dogs or something I did
really I didn't
I don't like [ __ ] I don't get queasy
around that stuff at all I don't know
why I pick up dogs with my hands like I
don't know what you just say throw it
over the fence no I don't have any
neighbors on my okay that's good around
me so I just died you crazy if you just
Wow
I never heard of anyone pick a way to
lifts when um when we run out of bags
but if it's to me a lot you have to do
it with I'll take a leaf leaf you out of
ground and I'll just do like yeah but
I've been I come pretty close to
touching it but if you touch my finger
I'm [ __ ] like a ruin my day
why do you think cuz it's [ __ ] yeah it
gets a bad rap rapid [ __ ] it's just [ __ ]
I once stepped in [ __ ] in Bay I had a I
don't know if it's a manic break or a
nervous breakdown and I'm not really
sure what the difference is but the
crazy if craziest I've ever gone
was in Las Vegas I had done like 58
cities this was maybe like 10 years ago
and I was at a casino called
the god it's it's not Treasure Island
it's a super [ __ ]
I'll think of the name of it they have
penny slots they're known for their
penny slots like it's like [ __ ]
zombie land mm-hmm and I it was July 4th
and I went into the bathroom that was
right because in Vegas you could be
inside for days and not go outside and
realize you're not getting any sunlight
or serotonin or human interaction and I
went down to the pool to try to like oh
like I'm gonna go outside I'm gonna get
some fresh air walk back into the
bathroom and I you know when you smell
there's a certain kind of puke [ __ ]
smell it makes you yeah like like an
automatic gag and I just was like good
like out of nowhere and I didn't know
what was happening and I was to go
someone puked all right someone puked
and um and then I looked down and I had
stepped in human [ __ ] and didn't miss a
beat picked up my shoe like just started
like washing it in the sink and I was
washing dig it out of the crevices so
I'm just washing this [ __ ] out and you
grab hysterically I'm crying and I cried
for four days I couldn't stop crying
cause it cuz you touch like I'm gonna
start crying right now something just
happened where like I just had I'm
touring for some Vegas I had been in
Vegas you had a [ __ ] break I just said
place is so wrong
it really is good it really upsets me
yeah it I take on like the sadness and
disappointment of everyone yes there
when I go that's all I see and the
drunken it like seeing people drunk
during the day with those big tall thing
the whole thing makes me and they like
all the way from Europe and say I have
to say that for this you have to be a
real degenerate to like actually I like
Vegas have you done that that flight out
that Friday at like 4 o'clock if you fly
to Vegas its people on the plane like
groups of girls bachelor parties they're
like yelling yeah they're slapping the
asses of the flight attendants it's
horrible yeah Vegas is an honest-to-god
hellscape yeah
Vegas the only time I've truly ever been
a family
where where was it woman go or something
appropriate oh wait Southpoint casino I
just remembered at Southpoint oh she's
out it's ten miles off you can say this
you can say you might say that the south
point of view stepped on what's a
stretch how do you how do how does
someone [ __ ] their pants do you have to
always check it out I had the flu and I
was playing poker and I was I was having
a good run so I pushed it to the limit
and I was like I gotta cash out and
walking back to the hotel room I farted
but it was a shark and what happened was
it started running down my leg you know
right away it's a shark yes yes just
warm and wet and you know that ain't
right but it started running down my leg
and I'm walking in the hallway public in
the public area that's a dark moment
with you're wiping this [ __ ] off I
didn't even bother I just like you ain't
cool go or did you used to go a lot to
Vegas yeah my parents lived there my
grandparents Wow uncle live there it's
jump you could have told us that after
we start trashing it did you love
gambling or do you animal I just I used
to play a lot of Poker so that was fun
but I don't like it yeah I don't like
anything there anymore yeah Vegas it's
it's hard it's also hard because there
are so many people that go to have their
big night out of their year yeah so many
people go there and it's like I mean
sometimes I do shows there and there's
women in like sequined gowns and I'm
like this is like there's so much
pressure because this is like the one of
the biggest weekend's of your year and I
just cannot get out of here fast enough
mmm I just also makes me nuts how
[ __ ] expensive it is everything
everything yeah and then well the most
obvious is all the people gambling and
how sad it is yeah smoking inside that's
so like barbaric you have some major
PTSD from childhood [ __ ] like when you
see someone smoking inside and you smell
it you're just like it's crazy that that
used to be normal
I remember going on I hop with my family
and they would say smoking or
non-smoking Wilde's smoking as if theirs
are at a restaurant I mean with kids
yeah you know I waited my dad would
always smoke inside the house and like
the we will all be in the living room
uh-huh and he's just like well if you
have a problem then don't sit here and
it's like well this is the living room
you said that yeah Wow so yeah we were
all sitting in my friends that smoke and
I'm kind of just like did you not hear
it's actually I mean it's also it $15
now I think like a backer it's like $15
oh yeah so you're rich you're just rich
at this dude when I was in college a
pack of smokes cost five bucks and that
was expensive I remember and you've seen
the warning yes yeah of course the
warning labels now you will [ __ ] you
are gonna die you will see this is gonna
die why I'm like sign me up but I hate
there's something about the way we're
hardwired to sort of be attracted to
someone who's I know how when I see guys
smoking really they hate that it's like
it's kind of hot
I hate it hmm I hate human nature
because we're I mean it's actually you
understand that yeah what about what
because we're done alpha males who break
the rules no but but you used to be it
used to be like a musician with smoke
and video it's like a guy seeing boobs
no boobs guy cigarette it's just
breaking the law breaking a rule Eli why
do you you were smoking when we met yeah
but what not like no but what about okay
tell me I just said I don't know like
you you it's it's a local thing it's a
look isn't it like and if your dad
smoked it the smell could have been I
guess comforting um
I smoked I thought I looked cool
like is it let's an 18 year old segue
because now you're talking about and she
wants to [ __ ] every guy that smoke so
here Thank You Anne I don't fight we
don't wait don't you really know do you
what's the biggest fight you've had in
less over like what food now we're gonna
orderly always fight about the other
nice you really annoy me she goes he
goes I know you heard this this is like
second row but it's so true with her
she's she goes we're gonna have to order
food tonight
so just Tom now that you're vegetarian
just tell me anything you want we'll
order it I go okay I want pizza or
Mexican food and then I could tell she
hates those option and then and then I'm
like okay what do you want
and it's always Italian and I'm like why
don't you just say that from the
beginning I know it's like the same joke
everyone says but it's so true you look
yeah just say of Queens episode yeah I
know it's that yeah you can also
schedule it ahead of time that helps me
sometimes so just pre-scheduled like on
Sundays I'll schedule what I'm gonna
have each night just to like be in
decision fatigue like because when
you're down to the wire and you're
hungry you're not gonna make it that's
my problem
yeah me too I guess when I agree I'm
like immediately in starvation mode
because there's not is there's nothing
extra in my side yeah so I go from like
zero to 1000 and over like 10 minutes
and I'm hungry right now yes and then I
get in panic that we don't even know yet
and then there's delivery time and so
I'm not even gonna eat for another hour
anymore
and then I need to start looking and I
just can't handle that whole process me
too
I kinda get very overwhelmed yeah and so
that's what happens and then I just go
to the first thing that I know I like
and that's Italian so I just you know
made it died but yeah they like what I
packed yeah you know what happened today
maybe stop baking Mexican food or pizza
what else is there I don't know he'd say
is Italian how dare you yeah it's
Italian you know what I did right now
when we came to the office we got
breakfast burritos and he'll only ate
half of hers and I stayed in the car to
eat hers she got out she put it in the
bag ready and then she got out with the
dogs and I stayed back in the car so I
could eat hers
in a shameful way yes all of it it was
just more like it wise if you stayed in
the college well eating more is the
number one most shaming [ __ ]
it wasn't more like oh I'm not ashamed
she's ashamed do you want to know the
darkest thing I've ever seen one time I
saw a woman in a parking lot eating an
entire birthday cake in her car maybe it
was her birthday I still think about
that woman if you're watching or
listening DME she's probably dead for
sure oh yeah oh she joked on her own
birthday cake vomit she's probably big
kind of I used to have really weird
eating [ __ ] like really weird so like
when I you eating disorder EP you can
see eating disorder you know and I saw
those guy I know what that is I just
like eating my car secretly [ __ ] like
that it really haunted me what kind of
stuff would you eat Louis I used to when
I was a teenager I had really intense
eating disorder stuff but it was really
more about control than about being thin
like I would only eat like a couple
things for like four months
you know really yeah like dried mangoes
and certain kind of smoothie and a
certain kind of yogurt with like rice
cake like I just had certain foods that
I could only eat and I eat them for like
breakfast lunch and dinner
I didn't realize until way later in my
life as in like a couple years ago that
my mom was for sure anorexic he's like
our refrigerator just didn't have a lot
of stuff in it and I remember going to a
friend's house and seeing all this stuff
in a frigerator
like what's all this [ __ ] oh like you
guys are hoarders like no this is what a
moderator supposed to look like we had
like wine and like Perrier and like
artichokes like that's all we ever had
in our fridge and I thought that was
totally normal but I was also like
really bin G as a kid like I would eat
like a box of cereal I couldn't just
have one no I was just very like a very
emotional eater and then the pendulum
swung the other way and then I was very
controlling about what I ate and I went
through a period where I wouldn't I was
terrified of fat like I wouldn't any fat
to the point to where it's like if I
ordered something in a restaurant and
there was oil on it I would like pad it
with a napkin to try to get the oil off
like I was just like you know delusional
about sort of how you stay skinny and
whatever and then I once I got to my
girl it wasn't related to being skinny -
I think that by the time I was a
teenager it started being about being
skinny and because I think I was getting
attention because people started
worrying about me and I was like oh this
is a way to get attention I think you'd
like just like worrying about you I
think on some level I would take any
kind of attention at that much you know
when people are like are you okay what's
wrong and I was like okay this is kind
of working and then I started doing some
fit modeling which is when you kind of
just stand there and they sew clothes on
you kind of thing so then I started like
working those okay so I need to stay
skinny and then I got into modeling and
started being told I wasn't skinny
enough it's crazy
you weren't skinny enough when I was so
skinny so then I sort of [ __ ] though
that escalated yeah I had a designer
tell me my ribs were too big you can see
my ribs are hiding shrink I was 15
crazy and then when I first got to LA I
was very Benji like I would eat a ton of
food and then I would go to the gym for
like three hours you know and I think
that was a big part of isolating because
I was really um shy and weird and it
made me like be able to not socialize I
think I was very close to being having
some kind of a disorder - when I was a
teenager yeah but I somehow I guess
didn't go there all the way mm-hmm I
think that and I try to talk about this
a lot like the word eating disorder I
think people are like huh I don't want
to have had one or I hate that I always
just also say like disordered eating
like I had disordered eating in this
area you know just so it doesn't feel
like it's like a big heavy diagnosis
yeah like it the way I used to look at
myself like I I was never fat I was
pretty much like this
and I used to think that like if I was a
little like if I ate something and you
could kind of see a little bit of
stomach I would feel fat yeah so like if
I was going to find you that in the
evening we're going out then I would
like not eat all day yes I don't want to
look fat in the evening I did that in
college I would drink like diet coke all
day so that I could like have pizza at
night I would try to like smile my butt
would you eat when you went out very
little do you think you had disordered
eating I mean I do because then looking
back now I obviously I probably looked
totally fine you know I mean totally
fine you were super I mean yours right
so I always get oh yeah
hey guys I'm so sorry to interrupt we
gotta go to break hey guys so sorry to
interrupt this is a bummer you don't
want a break time though for it it is
actually we just usually the story on
that is Bobby Lee was here and his
mother passed away recently I saw that
that we so we like to okay let's go to
the store to a quick break and we shall
be right back with the incredible and no
longer disordered eater Whitney Cummings
thank you it's easy
thank you to privacy comm / h3 for
sponsoring this episode of the h3
podcast let me talk about privacy these
guys basically lets you use virtual
credit cards online that are directly
connected to your bank account so that
you don't have to put your personal
information in when you buy stuff online
whether it's Amazon Alibaba or hentai
Express net I don't know if that's a
real URL not promoting them you can
protect your information for example our
credit cards keep getting stolen because
we're buying furry suits from China and
then let's try to spend our money doing
all kinds of crap but with privacy calm
you create your very own virtual card
and guess what they can't steal from you
anymore because it's got a limit it
works on every credit card field except
they can't steal it
you could set an expiration date you
could spread it send a spending limit if
you want to put it on like Hulu or
Netflix so they can't nickel and dime
you and keep that reoccurring payment
getting you good privacy calm has got
you covered
privacy calm currently on there free
personal plan you can create up to 12
cards a month secure merchant locked in
single-use cards and now privacy has
just launched launched two paid versions
pro and teams for pro you get $10 it
cost $10 a month you get access to
everything that's included in the free
plan plus 1% cash back on all purchases
36 cards a month and more security and
privacy features then you got teams for
those with a small business or in charge
of a team $25 a month access to
everything that's included in pro
version plus you get a dedicated Account
Manager access to 60 cards a month and
transaction limits tailored to your
business needs now here's what it gets
real juicy guys enter head to privacy
dot-com / h3 sign up for an account and
as a special treat new customers will
automatically get five dollars for free
that I stutter five dollars for free on
your first virtual card for our fans
that go to privacy dot-com / HD on your
first purchase for a limited time only
that's literally just free five dollars
so
privacy Cobb /h Lee sign up right now to
clear that gift and protect yourself got
age
thank you to teddy fresh calm the
hippest and coolest place to buy
clothing in the world in fact with this
holiday season coming up I can't think
of a better gift to give your loved ones
your friends your family and even people
you don't like because then they like
you for example we just came out with
some new stuff this golden necklace so
blinged out sold in one day and let me
tell you about this teddy fresh shirt
that's a teddy bear on a Tesla in space
and image - my favorite Elon Musk of
Tesla Fame and so much more this is a
limited-edition beautiful high-back
t-shirt that's available right now just
in time for the holiday season but we
got that and so much more and stuff is
selling quickly guys it's the huh I mean
people are scooping this up you get on
this this shirts sold out but we got so
much stuff we got our of wah we've got
the bags let me go two bestsellers like
I believe what's over here
oh the color-block hoodie and all these
crazy sides its natural Barbie you've
got beanies in a trillion different
colors you know you love them color
black hoodie come on tie-dye
it's all happening the zip up Hoodie
over at Teddy fries oh just too good
Teddy Fresno Girl get over there quick
the coolest place to buy clothes online
we are bad
[Music]
let's break the mic so we are back thank
you everybody for coming back how many
show of hands how many people skip the
head I like my door I know I try to make
them I like it because I think think I'm
just kidding good podcasters I also just
kind of like people I don't there's
something soothing about it it's like
you could take a little break I get to
watch someone whose personality I like I
like to see how good at reading people
are yeah I'm not that good at reading
well it takes time you're only on
Episode two I know but I read my own
audiobook like I know I'm good just when
I've been reading when I feel like I'm
under pressure I start to psych myself
out and I'm a little dyslexic like I can
invert words sometimes so then I'm kind
of and then you'll watch a full spiral
and some of my outrage because then if I
[ __ ] one thing up then I'm beating
myself up and what you're so dumb you're
stupid you not everything that's why I
like doing it like this mm-hmm
so we I can retake yeah really bad oh hi
pressure off I did one for whatever I
can remember that brand but my producer
all of us had a heart attack because I
had to do like 13 because I just like
this is just between me and myself
everyone we're leaving I was like I
gotta get this right yeah that happens
to me I think did you get better at it I
didn't find to her Ethan does it so he
should realize once you've done a copy
read like 20 times yeah you go you know
it yeah let me tell you about I had B I
think we have beat YouTube proved that
one time they made us do like something
that violated YouTube's Terms of Service
and that episode got polled yeah we had
beef with them what do you think it was
they had they wanted us to like show a
visual write to me on the bed and then
YouTube said that was a it's like a
commercial commercial cuz you're not
supposed to put commercial in cuz they
do that you can only endorse a product
but they only do that if you ask them to
write or if you
who serves ads so they don't want you
competing with them oh wow
some weird thing about you can see you
can it you can endorse products got it
so you can read an ad we can't show
yourself on the product which would be
it was like with the voice-over and
everything they said they thought it was
so much like an ad we've got beef with
Casper
so do you sup because don't buy Casper I
don't know I
you're watching your show I mean if they
want a promo code Whitney not okay let's
let's talk about something if you are in
a relationship let's say let me tell you
what happened latter knee we need to be
hypothetical Dan a producer gets an
email a fan mail she's talking about an
issue we talked about and then at the
end she says PS we have this segment
called The Bachelor with a h3 mm-hmm and
it's like a dating game mm-hmm Ian for
example was the first season of The
Bachelor intern and it ended in disaster
yeah that's neither here nor there for
this purpose of this conversation so she
says to Dan if you guys do season two of
The Bachelor I want to be a candidate
because I think you're really hot and so
then I go dan did you click the link
she put a link to her Instagram yeah and
then has Jenna's a girlfriend so I go
then you click the link right yeah and
he goes I didn't click the link I'm go
you definitely click the link to look
mhm and and then I got the email to she
emailed both of us I said I looked I
clicked the link and look yeah and then
either goes and then ela starts saying
you're you can't look if you're in a
relationship because you said you don't
believe then and it started by me saying
I believe then because he has a
girlfriend so he probably but we don't
look but it doesn't matter and then all
these guys started saying I wouldn't
look and I'm sitting here like everybody
like everybody would click that link
just out of curiosity it was in an email
yeah it was a email of
with a inquiry a comment on a show
uh-huh
and she did a PS I think you're hot and
here's my Instagram link uh-huh and you
clicked it
of course I clicked how long were you on
the page not long how long I mean like a
minute tops just again I want to scroll
yeah not more than a minute here's what
I'll say I have spent no more than 40
minutes with you and I I'm stunned by
how in love with you he is so I know
weird me out so I think it's healthy too
yes you know what I mean I I just think
that like there's always I mean you walk
down the street there's people
everywhere I think there's something to
be said for like I keep choosing you
every day regardless of all these
temptations what a huge compliment I
don't have much sensation and it wasn't
even written to me yeah and by the way I
have all my DMS closed like a
hypothetical like what would you say
she's okay if you got that email would
you look and I said yeah I would look at
it
mm-hmm and by the way so just so you
know you are on the right side of
history because the comments were all
ride or dying me and they said these
guys threw me under the bus dan is lying
well I don't believe any of them I don't
believe any of them here's what I when
someone says something somewhat untoward
I'm always on their side immediately
because I know their time the truth at
least you can engage with the truth you
can't engage with these [ __ ] so
to me the fact that you looked if that's
a point against you the fact that you
admitted you did now you're even you
know what it means so what I like to do
what I like about it is moving forward
if you did do anything sketchy I do feel
like you'd be honest about it you don't
even you don't need to sleep at night
wondering I don't know I would I don't
and by the way my dams are closed we're
very confident like yeah in each other
and every night I'm not a kid you got me
but I it just became like this
you got hypothetical that I was that we
didn't agree on but I don't even look at
emails so I don't really know I don't
thing feels odd to me
finished an email like so if someone if
I say let's say on my show that someone
sent an email saying hey here's a dude
for your assistant or something what I
have looked at know if it was Derrick
that you if they got really let's start
there oh I do it constantly I go through
my DMS I look at every day yeah oh yeah
oh you do oh yeah yeah well page she
looks at dick bags oh yeah but I'm not I
could but I also want to write jokes
about it I mean I'll have a battery on
if the guy if the guy I'm with was
looking at a photo of a girl
the IMing him but at first of all it's
not just a random guy this is different
I'm a mega famous
Marilyn sir I am a mega famous podcast
median correct
and all around whether this man who
wants a John Legend recently once
sexiest man people were upset about that
I'll tell you what I saw the comments
everyone 100% agreed with Ethan thank
you
and I had time to think about it you're
not making I am NOT does that seem race
I'm not I'm not like a religion person
that will not take back with this
automatic I am like a scientist that is
willing to learn and change their mind
okay so I am willing to say it both ways
do you want to look at that but now I'm
on your side because what I think [ __ ]
you no no but I don't think there's such
a thing as a right or wrong and
emotional I think emotion or emotional
seeing me and being push it in and what
a [ __ ] how dare you not be flattered
that this Queen gives a [ __ ] okay click
the link okay I'm glad I am glad by God
you know but so when you but so how many
do you get a lot like what percentage of
your DM predictor I get a wild amount of
dick pics I I'm just shy its I've never
seen any things that ever work or what
such a strange thing I don't never send
a dick pic of my life I've never
received one yeah in this position a
dick so is there any I love getting dick
pics because I love home decor and I
love seeing what's in the background
basically because my dream would be the
people just sent me photos of their
bedroom because I love seeing people's
choice especially guys cuz especially
guys bathrooms I love guys bathrooms
because you'd see products you haven't
seen in years
Irish Spring it's like Where's Waldo of
like where's the sliver of Irish spring
because every guy has some weird [ __ ]
bar soap I just love looking at guys
[ __ ] so it is it really is a walk down
memory lane I love dick pics the new
genre of dick pic I've been getting
lately is a guy sitting on the toilet
holding his dick come on
I think gratifying that I mean I don't
know if they're [ __ ] yes there is
like I feel even winning but at what
position is it like is it it's probably
from their fate their eyes right there I
level it's from here down and I really
so you see the toilet oh yeah yeah you
see the toilet and then we see their
pants around their ankles and I think
but there's a big psychology in depth of
field with dick pics where you try to
put objects next to it to give it like a
something to compare it to so I think
it's guys beat they're trying to make
their feet further away so they're doing
looks bigger do you know I mean someone
was trying to explain I think it was
Swardson was trying to clean ever sent a
dick fit so they never show their face I
don't get a lot of fit no because you
can't really get your dick in your face
in the same photo kind of smelly channel
I'm gonna do that that's nice challenge
for you I'm gonna send you a dick pic
with my face in it I want to find you
some good ones because I actually have
some good I do get a lot of dick pics a
lot of times guys like tight hold their
dicks in the dick pic I got one of a guy
jerking off in a dressing room and what
is it what are they going you know who
loved this Whitney would love this
I think it's kind of I I don't know if
it's like a power move or if it's like
to try to upset me because I don't think
it's a come get this dick I think it's
like she on the toilet here's my dick
how do you think it's done out of almost
anger residing so I think cuz if you're
on a toy that you're not trying to turn
anyone off yeah it's a weird opener
otherwise it's a weird way to ingratiate
yourself just I thought it was an opener
or yeah I don't know I don't understand
the psychology of the dick pic the only
way that I can understand is if you're
in a relationship and you're trying to
turn her on but my dick never turned
anyone this is my favorite one of all
time wait don't show it nobody show it
I'm just showing you know it's a guy
taking a picture of himself in the
mirror and but then there's a girl
behind him there's no I know my girl
hiding it's a photo of a guy naked
there's a girl behind him holding her
dick and he said that to me no what did
you respond no I just screengrab it in
to show that one's trying to be
provocative
I think so too I don't know I still
don't know the psychology of the dick
because I don't I've never seen a dick
without seeing the head or the
personality attached to me like I got a
kid that dare kick me that's what guys
don't understand you know what's funny I
think only guys want dick like that
because you have to like you have to
want dick to send a dick pic sex you
have to me is not good oh the dick is
not a hundred percent of what sex is I
mean it's mostly emotional that's what I
think that's most yeah most women with a
guy but like I think guys are the ones
that are obsessed with dick and to send
a dick pic it's almost the gayest thing
in the world
yeah that's saying my dick is so awesome
I love [ __ ] yeah oh you're gonna love
this [ __ ] like yeah [ __ ] huh no say if
you send a dick pic you might be gay but
I guess it was a guy if you have a great
dick mm-hmm and no one knows about
that's probably hard to go through life
right I think because you know there's
guys who are just like you're all just
hanging out and all sudden he's talking
about his dick it's like oh I get it you
have nothing else going on in your life
but there's some guys like that if you
have a big dick you just you need
right it's like you got this but I guess
it's like a girl with you know big yes
but it is she gets to show it and yeah
I'll show it I definitely like my
girlfriend's and I definitely show each
other our boobs and stuff you guys know
but like on display you walk around with
the cleavage up not you I'm saying girls
with nice Julie if you wanted a lot of
girls have that oh yes that's right you
can show it off even if you're not fully
showing it off yeah but guys can't we
were talking you can't show ball
cleavage no dick cleavage you can I
don't do you guys though if you have a
big dick you can't show your friends you
can't show anyone it's like only the
people that sex with can see it so there
must be an urge disability and I tell
someone about my [ __ ] awesome day
yeah then they send it to you is it
weird when your guy friends talk to you
about it I don't like I don't like that
conversation do you do lots of like guys
nights like guys hang no I don't have
friends I'm really I'm married with a
kid yeah but do you have like mutual
friends you know we have a mutual okay
we're actually our closest friends are
the ones with kids now ah that happens
but I don't like I don't I've never been
much of a guy talk III was always maybe
a comfortable and guys come and start
talking about their sex life or their
[ __ ] or whatever I just I don't respond
well to that yeah I think it's because
my dad is a creep and I've always
rebelled against creepy men because it's
always something that revolted me that I
didn't disliked about my own father yeah
that's very self-aware thank you but I
do also think that I would imagine a lot
of that talk is stemmed from insecurity
anyway so sometimes I try to have
compassion like when my dad runs like
definitely do that I kind of him like I
want to call you a creep but also I know
that the origin of this is insecurities
they just want a field and I probably
need to just give you a hug it
definitely take me so long to realize
that most of the things that I don't
like about people comes from them not
liking themselves yeah you know so it's
look at this vicious cycle yeah that's
very true
you seem like you work on yourself yeah
you know I go through phases of of
hating hating myself and loving myself
to speed why would you do either you
don't hate myself or load myself it's
it's a patent that's a longer
conversation but I I've worked really
hard to not think like that and not see
myself the way I thought my parents saw
me based on the amount of tension I got
or whatever I can be now I can be
disappointed in myself but I try to not
just have my default be I hate myself
you know I remember ron funches actually
don't know if you guys know Ron really
funny like his last comic yeah he's
really funny and he said something to me
that kind of changed my life in my
Instagram captions I'm usually
self-deprecating because you know I have
my self-esteem just hanging by a thread
and and I would I said something about I
had to get Invisalign because I have
this one [ __ ] up tooth and I had
braces but I couldn't afford to keep
them on so they came off early it was
this whole thing and I had some picture
I upload and I said Oh at this angle you
can see my [ __ ] up tooth or something
and he was like you know a lot of women
that I know that follow you say that
when you self deprecated it makes them
feel bad because their language she
doesn't like herself then why like no I
have no permission to like you know it
was just kind of this thing that I just
sort of realize that like projecting
that if I don't like myself or if I'm
enough self-esteem issues I'm gonna try
to just like keep it to myself
because I might be setting a bad example
or something so I started got a lot of
responsibility it was it's a lot of
pressure that's really agree with that
yeah I mean on Instagram where
everybody's photoshopping yakked
themselves look way better yeah I think
people are refresh yeah I'm gonna
disagree with that wrongfully he's very
I just think for me like like when I
personally find it like when I see
someone who's like posting this like all
positive vibe yeah post I don't believe
it
yeah neither do I I feel like I just
feel like being honest but I think to
just try to self-deprecating without
kind of much no yeah rying to grow or
fix it or put in perspective I'm trying
to break that habit
oh I hate myself I'm such a disaster
it's like I having a disaster and I've
made a lot of progress so sometimes I
just need to like yeah
update my software in terms of my
perceived myself because it is like a
crutch for me to lean on to like go to
that you know that makes sense you know
my problem I have is not accepting
compliments and that's really annoying
because when you're trying to give
someone a compliment and they just won't
accept it it's like just take the
[ __ ] compliment I have to argue with
you complimented right now I take it
back I don't even now that you've
retired we all human I know
saerom once tried to give me a
compliment I was like no I'm the engine
goes you know and if I can't just act
like I'm the kind of person who can
right now this evening yes is really
hard for me really
yes even gifts it's really hard for me
if someone gives me a gift to like open
it in front of them because I feel
pressure to like receive in a way that's
gonna move yeah I'm happy yeah I usually
don't like if ii really cuz they usually
suck really why are you looking at her
no I mean no I wasn't no what's a good
gift you've gotten I always I ask this
on my podcast I don't like that
really I say no gifts why it's too much
pressure
you got pressure to give you got
pressure to receive yeah just you know
what I'm saying yes let's not get and
what if I don't get you something as
good as you got me or vice versa or you
get me a shitty one I feel like and then
you got a plot what do you do for Holly
I have a problem with that though
because it's like you end up both sides
end up taking the lazy way out yep no
gifts above it and then I see my parents
50 years later and then my mom is like
he never bought me anything and well
that generation gifts are currency they
mean love like I feel like we're the
first generation that's changing the
West not truly law but what do you do
with gifts we do I eat other [ __ ] that's
he giving you something good well we I
mean we add that we want anything we
just buy it we share everything where
there's no separation there's no way to
even surprised it yeah there's the lid
really no way it's a surprise her I
can't we have one car
we got one Amazon account yeah one Bakke
account how am I gonna buy her gift I'm
big unframed we like oh that's that is
sweet you could take a photo of your kid
she's never seen I'll take a photo my
dick she's gonna what do you guys do for
holidays know that there was a hole in
you but you do present you don't your
presents now we should we'll do
something together like trip that's yeah
we'll go on a trip like on these
holidays we're gonna go on a trip with
our son okay
I mean we've gone shopping together we
went shopping together and like like I
check it out yeah I got the expensive
shoes you know yeah and I'm like I don't
know if I should buy it anything's like
you should it's your birthday yeah okay
so he's they're giving you it like the
gift is the confident be able to do it
guilty about yeah where did was your
last trip I won't ask about your future
one where was our last one I went to we
went to Mexico was that our last trip I
hate Mexico yeah your [ __ ] Oh words I
think yes Santa Cruz we like Santa Cruz
oh that's nice it's a slow road trip
yeah we don't do much fun stuff we have
work we were a lot of work yeah and now
we got a baby that makes things even
worse that's it's not much going on
sounds pretty sad no I'm very happy
together
I'm just trying to find a cure I see no
disagreements I see no passivation I see
no resentments let me ask you a question
did I buy a vintage car that's our
latest disagreement Ethan doesn't think
I should it's not because I don't want
to spend the money I don't want to have
it I know that it's just gonna sit in
the garage it's a pain in the ass to
upkeep it's just it's gonna
that is right yes you know it's if I was
if I was a hundred percent on getting it
I would but and I would support you yes
I says if you want it don't just this is
my I know you're gonna regret it and I
kind of know that he's right right I see
they want it I have a couple questions
are you gonna want to drive it every day
yes how much is she doesn't even drive
them probably not expensive yeah it's
like probably less than 20 grand mm-hmm
okay and how important is it to you I
just feel like our I'm bored with like
the black normal car I just want like to
see a little pop of color you're not
gonna like man no you should [ __ ] get
it okay I think you guys work your asses
off and you're a mom and you deserve it
I grew up with no money and now that I
have it I still live in this scarcity
plays if you have but it's just gonna I
do that I get very practical and I'm
like what the [ __ ] am i doing life is
short I've worked my ass off if I want
to get it and if it starts being a
problem get rid of it
but I feel like in the amount of time
you're spending deliberating about it
you could have just gotten it yeah and
either had gone right or wrong and even
if it is kind of a hassle and sits in
the garage if it makes you happy yeah I
don't see why not
if it starts becoming a problem then
you'll just get rid of it I didn't like
her answer I'm sorry I feel like I'm but
I just I'm big ugly kidding I reek to be
Tift I've always been so
premeditated about things yes and we are
like that we are both we didn't have
money I have a scarcity complex you know
and I'm just sort of if it's about
you've worked your ass off and I feel
like you earned it it seems like you
don't really go on that many vacations
and you just had a kid is it gonna be
convertible it might be you think it's
gonna be - no no baby no kids and also
if it doesn't work out you can put it in
a it's just wrong yeah you're gonna get
matching glasses that's all that idea
yeah you know you can you know you can
always put it in a garage somewhere else
if it starts to annoy you or it can just
sit in the garage I've already annoys me
yeah but that's my farm I need you to be
a hundred percent on the same page with
me
you're not all in so you know she's
hesitant she said she agrees with me but
she might not agree with you because
she's worried he won't be supportive you
know do you think I want to be
supportive no cuz I don't cuz I don't
want it to like a day after I get it
it's a nightmare and then you're like I
told you so I won't say there's no
version of vintage carving a nightmare
yes you would no they weren't vintage
they were old we were poor old there's a
big difference or just from like the
sixties I grew up in Virginia and tech -
it won't be that old so maybe it's your
definition of vintage I'm telling you
everything and from the 70s beyond sucks
and I say that as someone that knows
nothing about Porsche or something still
like I see you know but like maybe he's
a billionaire yes like people did take
care of it do you think this car is oh
wow this is like 50s or 40s if you crash
in that it explode that's what you want
okay so now I like the old BMW or old
Mercedes I just wanted people that can
like them right you can get those from
the late eighties 9 bucks yeah I like
that's an old Mercedes but just looks
like a dumb car but you hurry but you
can get one more than nineties nineteen
nineties BMW I'm sorry Mercedes I
conflate them that looks older than it
is oh these are this one is 45 Grand
I think if they work they're gonna start
right where were you looking like
Craigslist I just looked on Google image
you're sick that's incredible that's
probably like a hundred thou hear more
yeah I think that I think the price
finding one that actually works then
seeing how much money it is I think
that's gonna be what okay helps you
decide do some more research
yeah it's fun to just look at old cars
who else is good with old cars that we
know I know a lot of people that are
really good at old watches but we must
know someone that's good with old cars
Rogan has a bunch of cars Leno has a
bunch of cars I know I think has a
really old car yeah I know has like he's
known first deplane hangers I've been to
his garage with all the old cars and
it's not just old car I mean it's he's
got like steam engine car oh yes like an
old electric cars yeah oh cool
you should go there it's so [ __ ]
awesome and then he's got a lot of cars
that are there and you're like why is
this there because it was like the first
Mazda Miata
oh yeah is like the first of a little
what's Jay Leno worked oh wow I mean I
don't think he's ever talked touched his
talk show money they say hey Leno
network oh really
yeah because he makes so much money off
of corporates 400 really yeah that
tracks yeah maybe saves money on clothes
only wears denim tuxedos is that the
Canadian tuxedo I don't know why is that
I I agree that's almost um it's unfair
to the sweet Canadians but maybe they
just love denim people clown on Leno but
he has always been so kind and so nice
Howard hates Blenheim yes they have a
big but I haven't really followed up
mm-hmm
but um he's always really nice after my
special came out he called me Oh like
say how funny or what like he didn't
have to do that I thought it was really
nice we talked a little bit by you
special by though I've sure so I have to
tell you what the the one joke about
gold diggers was I don't know why I
loved it so much but I'm not that I
don't know why but I mean I don't know
why that one specifically you know what
I thought was clever about it yeah I can
interrupt you if I can mail if I can
mansplain why don't you finish so I'm
not mean I don't I don't have anything
important I do wanna get Carl's jr. Impe
beyond burger on the way home yes
they'll have you done the Burger King
beyond burger or only cars
yeah I did it Karl's little ones crazy
the Fatburger one no oh the Fatburger
impossible burger is a dude I don't
understand it's like so easy to be a
vegetarian now all this beyond meat
sorry
well that's the word like ten years ago
that was in Israel and I had like
nothing so so now it's so excited like
what do you want is summer yeah yeah
wait what were you gonna interrupt it
yes so um the the gold-digger prank or
the gold digger joke was great it
because it was a kind of a fresh take I
hadn't heard that angle you said maybe
if you didn't want to be dating gold
diggers you would just not go [ __ ] 18
year old is that the joke I mean
obviously I did it way worse we may in
your old but you know date women with
their own gold right yeah like that but
then I think I I actually stuttered a
lot during that bit I have a weird
speech impediment that sometimes comes
out thank you so much you list them the
others viagra and I stuttered during
that bit and I almost cut it because you
do see no one noticed except me and I a
was like magnified you didn't cut it and
then there was a whole thing about you
guys are gold diggers you took all the
gold or you already took off when yeah
when did it before we were laughs you're
literally gold digger literally gold
before women were allowed to leave the
house I'd love to go get gold myself but
you guys took it all yeah that's a good
joke - you are literally a gold dick
yeah yeah with well that kind of led me
into a show on YouTube there's something
really popular called gold digger pranks
that I have always pissed me off
really and they're all very Pro gold
digger I do what you got to do well here
I mean I wish I was smart enough to be a
gold digger right it's like you want and
you
young girl so now here watch this and
then you tell me okay look at the view
now before 47 million views now let me
just explain some things there's like a
million of them and they all have like
forty to sixty million views and I'm
also gonna tell you something I've it
does it I just feel like there's a
stigma against women that date men that
have money or power first what we're
wired to [ __ ] do that that's just
evolution in human nature 101 but I've
had men gold take me before you know if
male gold diggers are everywhere to and
nobody nobody talks about that oh you
had another good joke about that you
said there's a there's a name for the
male gold digger it's the backup dancers
Britney Spears you know like we must be
really in love yeah using her right
that's very true and she knows that
she's got some she got some dancer no oh
maybe so maybe okay well fair enough but
regardless so what you said is true
they're using each other now this is
where it goes haywire and everyone think
it's fake by the way and all the
comments are like yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you see but it's presented as real
what's up Judy what's going on hey I was
looking at you and I thought you were
really pretty and I wanted to get your
number
is that too much to ask for or let's go
out to dinner
oh yeah will you go to dinner by
yourself defense oh it's um I don't
usually ask twice but you sure you don't
wanna go out with me yeah that's my car
why I don't it's no notic it's a hundred
percent absolutely not but they'll heard
the message you'll see is what I want
you reactors it's baby too bad I don't
like gold diggers I just like young
girls that I just saw and I like their
looks and that's all I know about them
people worship this guy for that they
think it's so epic what a tool
right I mean I don't feel like adults
are watching this no like teenage it's
young see I mean yeah I don't really
feel like this is true I got kind of
deep into the sex robot sex doll
chatroom world and there is a lot of
this kind of waffle and so this is like
um like how girls grew up watching like
Disney movies and romantic comedies
would show that like all the bet that's
like the inverse version of that or
something like let me reinforce some
fantasy that's gonna be self-defeating
and none of my relationships in the
future you know that's like Disney
movies for Boris on about that yeah
here's their inverse yeah here's the
thing that's gonna [ __ ] up my paradigm
of wouldn't help me make like a sweeping
generalization about all women or this
is gonna justify the thing I already
think oh this is why girls won't [ __ ] me
now I feel better if it makes you feel
better about yourself whatever works
we all need anesthesia yeah but then
five years later your name is Elliott
Rodriguez and I'm saying so is this guy
like a YouTube maker yes okay I get to
make I love it sorry I video to me is
the shirt he chose to but like he was
doing an impression of a rich guy
that's just the shirt you would wear no
so I've seen these so it's basically
just they get rented nice car for the
day right and they try to pick up a girl
and then they come back with the car and
they can't wait to suck his dick yeah
but so no one knows this is fake it's
all it's presented as real yeah I mean
but what do people what if all these
views are people watching and having the
same conversation we're having
nope you know you don't get you don't
get to 60 million views from
conversations oh yes but there's four oh
I see yep yeah I mean a lot of people
know it's fake but most people are in
like look at the comments let's see I
mean I've never seen something yeah yeah
that's good that guys woke is she
working out and stretching on a car then
I realize well let me show you soon
because it's so show you the first scene
it's like the fakest I loved it look at
her she's stretching and yeah no yeah
it's not you'd be like that
women don't exactly yeah I would have
maced that person anyone who has any
modicum of emotional intelligence er has
been out in the world saying there's no
way he's like after you what is making
me one of me I have weird posture things
and I broke this shoulder and I've
started to kind of hunch so I'm trying I
almost got that thing a friend of mine
you know the community Neal Brennan has
has told me about it it's like a strap
that you wear with a little device on
the back that when you start to hunt it
chirps is it do you find benefits of
sitting at standing up straight or is it
just to look you know it's just my
posture yeah I broke this show it
definitely looks better but I broke this
shoulder and if you start hunching it'll
freeze you know did you break anything
any knotty problem gonna hang
we're all healthy good for you broken
his uh I'm just brainstorming how was
your childbirth is okay um you know
childbirth yeah no I don't you were
there I watched whoa I watched
everything they may I held her leg they
made me do it
my brother said he tried to film his
wife's first oh don't do that
and she started [ __ ] and she didn't
[ __ ] I surprisingly didn't I I was
totally expecting that I would well
that's well done I think it's because
I'm I think so I'm a nervous Wooper so
like when I get nervous I go to the
toilet like nervous to have something
tears no your she already had her bowels
the whole time that I knew that it's
happening I was running to the toilet
like okay god I got it if Whitney was
there she would have just grabbed it
with her I think I was already empty did
you get drugs yeah good oh yeah there's
a thing in LA where I was like I did it
with no dry no okay I act to Cristina
before and I was like yes big yesterday
drugs yeah great yeah I took it and I'm
very happy I did and you know I so there
were stitches I know someone a
girlfriend of mine Tora a total of 13
inches I don't know what I think that it
was probably a kind of bad Tara because
they were kind of hush-hush about it and
they were stitching you for a while for
a while but wait okay yeah so you get
all stitched up and then you don't
really know what's happening then you
just go back later and get the stitches
out yeah although it falls out or
disintegrates or whatever yeah it's like
the kind that like just and they're
inside you are outside both everywhere
yes pirates I in there yeah you know
anything she was [ __ ] up though hurt
you had like ice up in that [ __ ] all
day and get diapers on it you do
consider doing a cesarean like a
scheduled caesarian I first
I don't think it's worth it if you don't
need to yeah cuz it as scary as it all
sounds yeah it's weird to say that it
wasn't that bad
yeah Wow well that way yeah no I agree I
mean it wasn't as bad as I thought it
would be either yeah well your brain
does get flooded with oxytocin when you
give birth which is the only we had a
pretty good case of it I wasn't sick
throughout my pregnancy yeah I never got
it just like a breeder now and then
afterwards I pretty much went back to
normal so yeah it was hard I'm not gonna
say that wasn't yeah but I was expecting
like being traumatized for life
afterwards yeah I was really afraid of
it so like maybe my bar was like really
it like this is gonna be like worse I
expected something far worse to but
ultimately you just get through it you
know it's just it always on you it was
really totally it was it was their way
to me in the whole time huge [ __ ] I had
passed a huge poop and were you scared I
wasn't I mean I wanted to you let it be
comfortable I thought I knew she would
be fine though yeah sure body was was
adapting incredibly well to the
pregnancy when we got in there she was
all she was already like five inches
dilated which is like half the way there
and it's her first baby she was all
ready to go your next baby is just gonna
crawl out on its own do you think you're
gonna have another one yes do you want
to have another one and because we
because we want to Theodore his name we
want him to have someone to play with
oh yeah that's cute like a second dog
yeah yeah you can leave him home longer
yeah that's all you know you have
someone who can built-in babysitter
[Applause]
that was laughs sorry I get really loud
I think it's exaggerated but I think I
gave I think I murdered our baby I
startled you
this is how our baby reacts Theodore
doesn't like it
no Theodore likes it no no he does
people think it's fun dad really really
you can't do that is it like acid reflux
is that what as you feel acid coming up
mucus in your throat no I guess I almost
black out that he actually does that all
day every day at home - I were I mean
literally I feel so close to you I know
everything about your shits you just did
that yeah most people don't comment on
that I mean this is wild
I'm glad are you so comfortable yeah
well you know we like to get to know
each other that's just to get like stuck
to my balls it's like haha no I'm
unsticking it so guys we'll just do one
thumb I see it all the time and I never
quite know I don't know what they're
doing but I could speak for myself it's
sweaty or the water from your that you
left on your butthole it's probably
swinging up and it's uncomfortable so
you got a d-stick
okay what do you guys do when you grab
back there Zach all you guys what do you
guys do well UK you guys you're on
camera what can I do I'm not gonna be
someone else on camera I got a dick it
gets stuck to my balls like this I mean
she's the first person to come on it is
anyone else troubled by it I'm rich I do
have commented on it in in YouTube
comments oh I didn't never seen them do
you guys see comments like that oh well
you they just see you do this probably
yeah I think it's it's not a bomb I'm
just grabbing my dick and lips oh I
thought I saw a thumb no maybe like a
hitchhiker thumb just straight down why
don't you guys speak up I'm asking you
guys questions you just leaving me in
the trenches like usual I mean do i I'm
not on camera constantly okay well I am
so what do you do you grab your balls if
I need to sure yeah but do you can you
not not do it like how uncomfortable you
you read comments are people troubled by
it I don't read them regularly anymore
but I've seen it for sure Dan have you
seen that it's it's out there I wouldn't
say it's the most common criticism but
what is the most I've I'd like to see if
I agree with it
well I'm gonna get my list out most
common criticism I don't know I don't
think people criticize me at all can you
guys the gift you can provide me is a
supercut of all of his throat clearing
oh that's so funny my problem is that
people think it's funny because he does
it on videos but he does it at home too
yeah well nonetheless there we go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Oh funny your brand yes very big part of
your brand reflux do you take something
for it yes we take a map result 20
milligrams Oh
every morning you know it's like a big
thing people say it even like will give
you Alzheimer's and [ __ ] but I don't
have a choice
well cuz it's sorted start to eat it
you're not focused or something no it's
not good for you right if you have all
that acid yeah that's not good
yeah but they say that like the a map
Rizal can cause I don't know people
don't really know they just give you
[ __ ] and they don't know what yeah but
it's if you don't take it oh it's so
much worse does I just have like
constant heartburn all the time oh god
it's so nice what happened in the early
videos he didn't know that he had it and
and he was coughing all the time and it
was real people thoughts that he was
just like exaggerating for the video
right right but it was it was real and
then eventually like after a year or two
only you realized that you have yeah I
said to reflect omeprazole was a game
change has not been eating meat hounds I
don't know it's only been like a week
but I I mean I've had the the Harper
under control yeah I think in general
yeah you know and one of the more a
cough the worse that guess cuz it starts
to injure my throat yeah make awful are
you talk for a living I talk for a
living you know I I got something here
yeah I put together a list of our
favorite cringe videos actually I've got
the the gender-reveal parties to which I
know you're passionate about
let me give you some headlines let's
start there
small plain gender yeah I mean the whole
premise is outrageous yeah it's oh let
me show you this one this was a recent
one that came out of Russia that I think
you'll enjoy Russian gender reveal today
this is gonna be a [ __ ] tell me what
you is that Russia that looks like the
valley I can't imagine a better way to
celebrate everything see her getting
blasted in the face was hard what
[ __ ] [ __ ] they just hang there to
you know she's just showing and joined
the just enjoying a blindfold and that
was this yeah now she was like oh it's a
boy and I just and now I'm gonna have a
miscarriage for sure [ __ ] I'm pregnant
with a child I should probably inhale a
bunch of chemicals it's a boy now but
it's gonna be a fish when it's born yeah
they say that exhaust is is not well
that was like some like food coloring or
something good I love that it's like hey
you're about to provide the gift of life
can you go squat behind our car is it
park like what I don't want this [ __ ]
baby yeah I mean in a girl romance
that's romance did you hear about the
gender review of that started 47
thousand acre wildfire I did have you
seen the video no there here's the video
of it starting fin-tastic wilds Arizona
gender reveal party turns into a blaze
Oh what an [ __ ] I mean dude you could
have figured look at forty seven
thousand acres oh my gosh
what's of human garbage was it a boy
though was boy right you got Jesus it
was a boy so we have so we know Elise
okay well I think it was blue smoke yeah
the boy okay I mean they had to pay
eight point two million dollars you had
how did you guys know the gender of your
kid before was born yes how was it
revealed
ultrasound yes isn't that on the agenda
really I don't understand why aren't
there enough surprises in child that you
need to add surprise Oh also in Israel
it's not a thing so I was really shocked
when I first started revealing it yeah a
people started I skin us like do you
have a David plan for the gender-reveal
and I was like text message yeah I plan
yeah I I think that we have to remember
though like I always forget that most
people don't get to have big like
parties and celebrations and attention
and I think Instagram has made it that
people are trying to do stunts anymore
offense that's right that will get them
Facebook like we get a lot of attention
I think most people don't and I think
prankster culture has made people go
like I gotta do three things to get
likes on Instagram yeah kind of a boring
person of iral yeah I think everyone's
kind of trying to get their moment
that's a good point you know and shits
catching on Oh to hear about what if
your Isis and you want to terrorize
America yeah why wouldn't you just come
to California during this fire season
and just throw some matches here and
there yeah like that's the best way to
cause terrorism to this country um it
already happened in Israel so they would
if they were here why aren't they I mean
you're just not under attack every day
like in Israel it sells out that they
were slicker I just talked to the guy
that does Apple podcasts sure that
whatever and I was asked him all these
questions and he said Isis had a podcast
and tried to upload it Isis podcast
brought to you by the ketchup Jasper I
just was like they recorded another one
bad of jihad they were I wonder what's
the name of it I don't know seven
version lots of questions vanilla Isis I
don't know how many virgins do they get
oh wow yes one get seven they get 72
what if they bomb something you know
they get you know they get bored though
and within eternity that's way too much
time yeah you you why does nobody know
that verse
virgins probably aren't that good at sex
yeah but that's what they like they want
them to suffer a thing they're like I
don't want I just want to nut and I want
you to suffer god I got it got it got it
I'm gonna like cause pain to you okay
copy that 72 is such an odd number it's
probably there's probably like I know
like in Judah 72 I think there were
seven women and Muhammad's harem mm-hmm
I just made that up
thank you I'll probably gonna get death
threats for that joke anyway yeah do you
get a lot of death threats what they say
in the death threat of someone who's
actually gonna kill you
doesn't give you a heads up yeah exactly
which is even scarier yeah they just
show up yeah I'm trying to put like
secure my house more and the alarm guys
like look if somebody's here to harm
your family they're gonna you can get a
real dog I think well I have a doctor
real I shot a full shot dude I use it
yeah oh good I've it's loaded it's in a
gun safe mhm and basically um units a
semi-automatic seven shots no reloading
oh that's hard our quick style good have
you done training and practicing yes too
long of a pause I've shot it I know I
know how to you know how to use it do
you know how to use it you lose kills
with her hands I love to see you
shooting a shotgun like boom boom just
to let him know yeah anyway I was just
saying that that hat did happen as if
there are attack fires
yeah they stout they should outsource
that to America I'm just saying I don't
want it to happen but it's really good
like if I was a terror if I was like a
how to terrorize caption it but I just
I'm captivated but yeah I feel like
they're planning something probably a
little more digital or something
mmm what's this one this one's well
Israel is like Simpsons did everyone at
all Ohio Oh
Australia you know what um there was one
okay what's she doing they put
timestamps on a one-minute video it's
like alright come on this is so
ridiculous I just want to say hinted
windows about that topic still they've
even used kites ok ite yeah like what
did you think she said well kite I don't
know I was like cakes please don't get
into that ok hey ok thank God we're back
yeah
kites to fly explosive stuff into people
get creative they have more there yeah
they're more creative over there yeah
anyway only our terrorist could learn
something from them yeah that kite
technology yeah I think the Japanese did
that too during world war two they like
flew [ __ ] blimps with bombs across
the ocean I know I feel like I've been
reading so much about terrorism lately
but then there was this article in Time
about how like the next big attacks
gonna be cyber terror like we're focused
on keeping arsenal save me while they're
in cyber terrorism territory yeah I do
you think they're sophisticated enough
that probably comes from like China or
Russia or something
tik-tok they're gonna take a [ __ ] yeah
you know do you know that tick tock is
owned by a Chinese company that sells
our data I mean yeah we have lots of
thoughts on that it's like no one's
gonna stop giving out their data like no
never gonna stop so we're running around
and thinking about it but and it's that
ship has sailed
yeah you know it's just like I think the
most important thing is you're like your
health information and you know like the
therapist I go to like I just don't go
through insurance because I don't want
any of my meaning about my personal
mental or physical how old you know cuz
that's that's what the real thing is I
think people all they do is complain
about data my phone numbers gonna leak
it's like do you remember there used to
be books with everyone's phone number in
it in the dress in their own line no
everyone still exists so if you want to
protect yourself I mean I think it's the
one of us vulnerable populations are
literally just people that are aging
that used their mouse Google is
collecting data on when your mouth
starts just slow down or be a rat I can
selling to your insurance company that
you might be proposed it's really more
about your health information so that
your insurance you know you can't be
denied insurance that your insurance
doesn't go up you think that they sell
that to the insurance company so that
they can raise their premiums for sure
yeah there's a great that's crazy
it was either a hidden brain or
something that guy from Facebook who
advised Mark Zuckerberg to stop doing
that and he overrode his advice anyway
basically it's come out saying here's
all the thing they things you do anytime
someone sends you a Gmail any time you
use a Gmail they're taking all your data
anytime you buy a prescription you know
all the ancestry stuff I've really mixed
on that because they are using a lot of
it to solve unsolved crimes and they're
getting innocent people out of jail and
they're you know people that murdered
100 women are now going to [ __ ] jail
the Gold Coast killer that's right they
cause that's exactly right
and people that have been wrongly in
prison or getting out of jail you're
also using it to do studies but at the
same time you know if you're predisposed
to cancer predisposed to Alzheimer's or
something they can think theoretically
that could get to your insurance company
well you know who owns 23 me know Google
oh yeah helix I did the National
Geographic one oh those guys are the
best yeah they want they want I don't
know they won't sell your data to
somewhat to a I'm going nowhere bow
mining come you know what I'm saying but
I just always on the we're always like
worried about one thing that's like kind
of harmful and missing I mean the
security cities there soon there's gonna
be no evidence with Photoshop and deep
fakes like soon ever true you know soon
you know your photos you're gonna be on
a porn stars head and it's gonna be
understandable already has already had
success you know cooked off to you the
deep fix really know is that what I have
a question what would happen there if
you went out of town for a month
would he be allowed to jerk off to a
deep fake of you because technically
it's not your I think so what would you
care if I jerked off to a you a deep
fake anyway don't care yeah but it's not
your body but at least it's like I'd
rather someone else's face in your body
I don't know you rather him just
watching or your spouse watch porn I
don't really care about porn that but
what if your face was on the Heaphy like
the face is more of a meaning that
you're still there no and then your
buddy
that's it good you filled out I am so
would I prefer and jerk off to a deep
fake name
no cuz I'm kind of insecure about my
body oh so that's the kid I think it
depends on what the body look like I see
if it was like some crazy muscular like
super in shape body
I then wouldn't want him to like see my
real body me like oh yeah I have to go
back to coach right you know I mean I
think that would make me insecure I
don't think that would be I don't want
to I don't the bar getting too high also
he doesn't make the deep fake remember
someone else does it takes a lot of
effort yeah it really does so I would
just go type either deep fake and I
would just get it done
I've never done that though mm-hm and
that's legal I mean they haven't even
figured yeah I don't know that they've
legislated it yeah that's the thing is
that they're not really moving on
legislating and it's not until like
Lindsey Graham gets deep fake and he
should they can also put your face on a
murderer in a you know surveillance
video eventually that'll be spooky as it
gets but I definitely want males I want
Lindsey Graham's face on blacks on a
black
then we'll get that is they don't block
black comments when they take a bunch of
huge boxes with giant [ __ ] and they
have sex with a tiny little white girl
Oh glad I didn't know that I got there
not it not met there a doc I've been
about how I yeah i know i have a whole
bit about how like horn is the most
racist [ __ ] ever but they get it passed
cuz it's born black dot commons like no
one can report the racism because then
you have to say you had watched it right
i was pretty big deal it was because at
like 9:30 a.m. I woke up a little bit
Lake so soon stamp the night before and
I had like 18 text messages from like
all my guy friends are like dude
returning on pornhub
you're trending on point on all my guy
friends and I was like I'm glad to know
that you jerk off at 9 a.m. yeah all my
guys I think eyes jerk off at night I
don't know why Oh
all hours 9 a.m. coming in hot but yeah
I was trending I was like third training
on pornhub and I was like you know this
is a big deal it was a really big deal
were you in a way are you at all
flattered by a Nipplegate I was I think
most people probably would look at my
nipple that like I was extorted and it
was put online Mart of curiosity I just
I'm so bummed because it was just like
the least flattering [ __ ] I've taken
very good nudes before this was not a
good news although it's just well for
context you did an Instagram story yeah
you're known I was stoned
okay good we have a little comment a
little context we there was a little bit
of nipple on the bottom and then why
taking a video in the bathtub sort of on
Instagram and I was a little stone so I
didn't really see and then I uploaded in
and I like looked at my phone like 10
minutes later on like 45 minutes on the
internet and I was like only one nipple
like what happened how bad is my posture
that's only one it's like half really
yeah it's like and then I and then I
took it down and then like three months
later my specials coming out and I got
this email from an AOL account like a
great flash I already know this is
either a criminal or Isis or my aunt and
I open it in this guy and he's like um
you know if you don't pay me $50,000 I'm
gonna
this photo what is yo mass was publicly
posted
well I publicly posted after that but it
was on it what a genius that's right but
it was a video that I take him down and
he had screen grabbed it okay so then I
ended up just posting it anyway but it
was such a [ __ ] bummer cuz the photo
was like I was in the bathtub like kind
of hunched it look like I was having a
home birth was not flattering and and
you know how like when you bend over
your tits get kind of like skinny they
look like otters like they're in the
background you can see like dandruff
shampoo and like great like it's such a
beauty and [ __ ] that guy yeah was I mean
and it's also the kind of snow pathetic
honestly like I do think that because I
was that we got to this whole legal
thing because you know extortion is
illegal in most states but I also it's
legal in some states think it actually
is I think it's only like 30 or so
that's crazy I know it's pretty wild and
I started really getting into it first
of all to sue someone is really
expensive and I was like I don't have
this person anymore my summer energy and
I think we I started to ascertain I just
had this gut feeling that it was like a
kid who was kind of just got in over his
head
yeah and you know we used to egg
people's houses we used to prank people
I was just like I don't want this
person's life to be ruined cuz they just
did something dumb when they were a
teenager and I don't really give a [ __ ]
I'm a comedian who [ __ ] cares mmm I'm
not gonna run for president someday
I don't bitching so I kind of was just
like who gives a [ __ ] yeah you know what
I would have liked it to have been a
posed photo well hmm I wonder if I
wonder you know you almost started a
trend I feel like there was people who
were faking oh leaking their nudes after
that well I did no I basically just was
like this is really embarrassing and I'm
just gonna post it and then Bert
Kreischer and a couple people just to
make me feel better
started posting embarrassing photos of
themselves which is really actually kind
of touching posted his balls Segura pose
Wow yeah yes
it was pretty much I think that's how I
found Nipplegate is that I saw Tom's
mangled penis on my timeline and
response as I grow all right I do I just
realized that there's porn on Twitter oh
yeah they know anything
yeah good but on Twitter you can't do I
didn't yet on Instagram you can't and I
did get shadow pans I got because I
violated the Terms of Service and I'm
uploading the photo when it happened so
yeah like out of the algorithm yeah but
I did they got me back and it was fine
because they all comedians are like
shadow banning is like the big two they
don't tell you but they just suppress
your engagement or what what does that I
don't I don't know I'm sort of like
Santino Hinchcliffe Tim Dylan like we're
all kind of like I usually it means
you've just violated the Terms of
Service and they take you out of the
algorithm so Santino had posted a photo
of like those nude naked news girls in
Canada or something so I think that's
why I think there's a logical
explanation for ID I mean what do you
think do you think Twitter's over there
going I don't like their political
beliefs um no I just I don't think that
they have I think I don't know that
Instagram doesn't over but I think if
you post a nude they tell you they're
like are you suspended yes you violated
the Terms of Service and then I was not
like searchable for like a couple days
I'm gonna be and then it was like
Whitney fan pages and then my page was
like so hard for I've seen that on
certain pages it's so bizarre yeah okay
so I think it's probably just you get
out of there algorithm in its machine
that makes sense the main feed algorithm
so weird anyway now like most people
don't see your main feed posts right
kind of thing so I don't know well I
wonder can maybe I should leak a picture
of my penis or something you see what
happens yeah this is a theme that keeps
coming up in this conversation dick pics
oh yeah that's true ball cleavage I
think breast feeding is the big saga
with Instagram like can you show
breastfeeding the whole thing with
Instagram makes no sense to me because
they'll allow pretty much nudity except
showing the nipple that's right
wait dear their song I've seen girls
just showing ass without yeah under
yeah you can show that so what I don't
understand except for vibe milk making
other nips men can yeah of course I
could show my nips big-time yes yes you
can I gave an extent I wonder if I can
extend my nipples you know some in like
they'll like extend their nipples with
like miss nipple sucker oh you don't
need to make me bigger so I'm wonderful
should get some big and gorgeous nips
and show those can I get like nipple
implants I forget nipple implants you
know learned a lot what if I get fake
tits as a dude I know those uh no yes
you probably can but you see what I'm
saying yeah I think you actually could
if you got breast implants as a dude you
could probably you were just a fat dude
with big tits I'm sure you could right
there yeah but I did learn when I got a
sex robot made of myself I went down to
the sex robot Factory and the most
popular nipple was large like like the
boys I was so interesting that nipple
guys like nipples that are as big as the
boob I don't like that guys like oblong
nipples I like I like a small supple
nipple yeah that's a diamond like
proportional yeah not like tiny but yeah
like I have like not like a man like a
freckle not like a freckle you like more
breast tissue than nipple you definitely
yeah yeah I mean I'm more the weirdo
here that can't be I like your point
about it for the women out there to know
that there's someone for everyone yeah
because we all I feel like we all think
that like you know you would want the
one perfect yeah we can they Paul
everyone thinks you need like a little
light pink tone is known to thee so I am
a monster yeah no it was just more like
they're a lot of guys request oblong a
lot of guys request dark really dark
nipples which is interesting
biologically because apparently your
nipples darken when you breastfeed it's
the wing me finds the nipple so that
could be like some mom issue
breastfeeding interesting I can't
imagine even like specifying and such
fine tea like if you were to order a sex
doll you know say she left you right she
couldn't stand the car yeah
I always rely being anything and so it
wasn't for her and if you had to get a
sex doll mate or if she was just like ah
the stitches aren't healing up I need a
couple months off can you just get a sex
doll like what would you custom order
you could decide everything pubes I mean
I know that's a lot of decision making
it is right they have a wall with all
the different kinds of nipple you choose
from there's like 48 different nipples
you have to just how much pubic hair you
want how long how what she it's kind of
too embarrassing to decide one of those
things oh really
this is where we draw the line I mean
just for myself like to live with myself
like the fact that someone may see that
someday and that I chose this specific
length of pubes or this specific nipple
I mean it's so embarrassing yes I find
the sex doll thing to be I wouldn't make
sure that that thing never saw the light
of day I would put it in it I want to
kill it I would just keep it like as a
as like a stepchild you don't like I
would chain it up in the base that's
what you do where do you keep my keeper
in room upstairs III put her in the
garage as we felt weird I don't think
she's creepy I everyone finds her so
creepy when they come to my house and
see her they're like who like they three
cat like people really get this very on
case it looks like so much like you yeah
and also not but you know it's wild
I don't think she looks like me at all
because we only see ourselves in Reverse
because we only see ourselves in photos
that's true you have no idea what we
look like they say that if we were so
dysmorphic if we were to see ourselves
on the street we might not even
recognize ourselves so when I look when
she first came out because I was like I
wasn't sure if I was gonna put her in
about that cuz I was like what if she
looks like a [ __ ] ratchet scarecrow
like I didn't realize how good the
technology was and they brought in this
like hardcore robot I knew it and press
that expression and so she came out I
was like this probably gonna suck and
I'll probably just do like a video with
it or something and as soon as she came
out I was like [ __ ] she doesn't look
anything like me and then all the camera
people with me really but there's
nothing fascinating to me when I learn
about why men are really creeped out by
our sex robot sex job
is because we're hardwired to be
repelled by anything that looks human
but doesn't look like a human like the
uncanny valley
it's our way that we've evolved to be
repelled by anything that looks sick or
dead so they will [ __ ] right it's called
pathogen avoidance oh I've been worried
I guess that just didn't I didn't evolve
with that because you're into the into
the dot if you're a creep another joke
[Laughter]
no I'm not I'm not a comedian
really I'm just would you do stand-up no
I love the fact that you are so
germaphobic about your butt but you'll
put your hat little bit on your head
germaphobe say that's such my own
[ __ ] I know but you're putting it
over your hair in the germs in that hat
arch that is so [ __ ] germs in your
mouth are going on to that and then the
germs from your head are all mixing
together your face is a petri dish also
has guises I hate hasn't foreheads - how
much does it cost to get a sex doll a
lot of money I would definitely if the
body and the head is what's expensive
because the head is in really only like
the world it's incredible Wow the body's
like 10 grand and those are disposable
so if I travel with her around the
country like when I brought her to
Howard Stern the Today Show and stuff in
New York
we sent a different body and then I
carried her head on the plane but then I
have another body at my house so she can
have many bodies her head is with
expensive and I bring it on a Pelican
case on the tip like a special case for
ya Pelican case that she I have to pack
the head in the hole take the weaves
expense five grand looks real it's
expensive his [ __ ] is it mate can you
make out with it um you can I don't I do
not you but I mean like let's say really
if you're in a relationship in you're on
tour and often would be maybe he's like
sex doll yeah I I just feel like it's so
expensive
yeah it's it's very expensive I know I
also put pantyhose on her and men are so
perplexed by pantyhose that she belt I
feel like he would just be like what if
you were on pantyhose
you wear what do you call him hose
tights leggings
oh you mean yeah like leggings like nude
pantyhose when guys see pantyhose they
just think your vagina disappeared like
they don't understand if it matches your
skin what do you call those like
something more like leggings or tights
tights yeah like tights so what is
penny.hope there is another word for it
yeah lady word for it that's like the my
mom is like the most unsexy word yeah
because it sounds like your grandma it's
like just it's like a panties with hoses
it's a it's like nylons it's like a
thing that covers your leg yeah I think
a lot of people now do the spray-on
nylons have you seen it's like a spray
and going up to pray like covered your
pores on your leg gotta get into
Hollywood I've seen Kim Kardashian yeah
thing about talking about it the body
makeup yeah yeah oh so they do that
instead of the pantyhose yeah pantyhose
I do get a lot of dm's of guys saying
can you wear pantyhose and send them to
me I think guys are in the pantyhose
yeah which is probably a mom thing cuz
their mom Wharram dude you get up a lot
of wild dams man I tell you I'm I bet
you have a lot of feet I don't look oh
yeah one website where they show
people's feet somehow reason you're on
it I am I bet yeah oh I hate food I
don't yeah as we say what is the foot
thing I hate I don't get the foot thing
statistically the most disgusting part
of body I know it's like the most
probably the most popular fetish is it
it's very cool what's the biological
basis for that fetish do we know
no huh I did it all yeah I'm trying to
relate to it but I think people just
like the it's petite
I think it's email okay you know it's
kind of weird I think there's also some
kind of submissive thing like I'm a
piece of [ __ ] and I only deserve to lick
your dirty feet there's a little bit of
a stress thing yeah like I'm garbage
yeah femdom yes it's a way to be the
whatsit yes there's a sub-sub and dog
and Dom okay right either
daddy Dom oh yeah what's that it's like
when you attend your baby and your
partner is daddy and change your diaper
instead I have great domain there's this
one girl that we often talk about on
this podcast who was into daddy Dom okay
so she likes guys who dress up as babies
no she's the baby she dresses as the
baby yeah and he [ __ ] her I don't know
if they [ __ ] that's kind of passable
pedophilia dressing as a baby is a joke
dressing as a baby still die see she
wears she wears braces to make herself
what is it it sounds like every picture
of me where you can see my face oh he
said that wait is it on Instagram I want
to look oh I don't know it's I found
it's a website called wiki and I was
like hey something I'm popular you do
have good food really I feel like I
don't I think you do because don't I
can't I don't know how to explain it you
have very normcore feet like what are
you like size 8 know what 9 9 okay see
I'm a 10 you have thin delicate looking
if it's complex about her feet really
does she has big feet just like varies
Dan I want to see this [ __ ] do you guys
mind if I get my dick out or is a
I sent it in the discord is that too
much for this moment is your dick in a
picture no I just gonna jerk off another
job on his podcast he showed you his
balls was that I picked I'm starting to
okay yeah really bad oh cool Lila we
have been here for five I mean we I mean
I'd be shocked I'm starving I mean we
might meet her ran out about two hours
ago this car this person is that [ __ ]
he should not be able to vote no oh oh
my god oh my god save the pregnant look
at just not pregnant
no if the baby has no dad what the drone
stole honestly probably better off yeah
without this genetic lineage well that's
so we've come to how long we've been
going down just under two hours okay
there you have it
who's the longest guest you've ever had
well to be frank with you we've gone for
eight hours we've had a charity stream
oh wow Aegeus that's intense
so that's like stupid but like average
guest I mean we don't go about two hours
is average like threes along Rogan
sometimes about three three is too long
oh yeah such a sad sight the mic group
in like that I know it the mic is like
I'm done
oh my god my makeup is on the microphone
talk about [ __ ] germs so someone
else's there's bobbies yeah might be
what else we have a bunch of cringe
fears but let me show you this one this
one's my favorite oh you have something
well I was just gonna ask what are you
up to these days like you're starting a
podcast and yeah and are you touring a
lot I'm touring starting in March Break
yeah I'm on a break from touring Whitney
Cummings calm yeah bus tour yeah but
it's not up yep it's not on yeah yeah
I'm announcing in Thanksgiving I'm sort
of full-time focusing on the podcast we
did Dan levy from shits Creek and Dave
Grohl
just a D'Elia pavulon ugly
they're coming like kind of just silly
yeah I think I'm overthinking the
podcast right now I'm excited to get to
a place where I can just show up and
just be authentic and talk stuff I spend
way too much time like trying to prepare
I feel like the beginning is hard don't
be taking a while to find your you're
and then I listen back to it I'm just
like I'm [ __ ] rambling like that's
boring I'm stuttering I would say just
don't don't be too hard on yourself
because it takes a long time mm-hmm we
hated it for a really long time yeah I
had to stick through hating it and
myself how long did you hate it for like
a hundred episodes so I only have 98
more to go and that'll have fun it can
take that long yeah like it was
something we wanted to do so it was like
a struggle because we weren't happy with
it or with the process or with how it
came out whatever but but we did want to
do it so it we just kind of kept pushing
hmm you know like I've been doing other
people's podcast for so long that I kind
of been like okay I'm trying to learn
from there the things I like and don't
like a bit about doing other people's
mmm but I try to just be really quick
and tight because I just assume
everybody's like so busy and you have to
be sort of like non-stop entertaining
but I think you know most of people I
talk to her like no I listen to it like
doing laundry yeah like yeah you know it
doesn't have to be like rapid fire TV
and sand apart yeah it's doing the
opposite you know my my first
inclination was that and people started
complaining that it was too short
oh wow well that's a compliment better
than too long I guess so but I think
people just kind of want to hang out
with you and that's something I need to
yeah good come give it at least 20 ups
though don't don't get too bad on
yourself you're exploring the idea yeah
yeah no we've changed stuff along the
way until you find like how you're
comfortable we changed the layout of the
room
yeah we've changed the mic in his case
you know it's all kinds of things that
you'll come to understand as you do it
though right yeah just kind of we're not
like podcast probably not hundred fifty
yeah
Joe Rogan's done like 10 million episode
no I think he's is it how many juice
that yeah 130 some 1,300 that's so
ridiculous Wow but he does a couple of
week but he's suffering walking
I think doing his podcast so much and
watching like that I'm like that's not
exactly what I'm doing so don't even try
to yeah you know yeah but he also
doesn't try to be funny all the time
either no you know but I think as a
comedian it takes a second to just like
shut that thing off I totally animate
anyone laughs in ten seconds what's
going on you're bombing like I have that
in common sometimes yeah you know and
embrace dead air
whoa there embrace it
where did you learn that at broad anti
broadcast school embrace the dead air
doesn't let it breathe sometimes we have
dead air offs we go okay dead air time
like watch right now you see you look
and she's not good at she broke the dead
air but sometimes you hit that air and
you panic don't panic just just do like
this and your guests just freak your
guests out just go just take it in
is there anything else that's brave
there's it's [ __ ] great
I mean stand-up is the same thing
stand-up is like them slow down take it
yeah it's a dead air yes and then the
next thing's gonna be funnier if the
audience is like if you build some
tension and just play it up I always go
I love going dead air
and now there's no exactly what are your
major slogans dead air another joke and
and I don't joke and that's a dick pic
I'd look at like don't you have like
mottos like there's what are your major
it's kind of in fascinating what are
your brand's words like what would your
Papa babe Nash and know combined papa
john and god bless ya papa bless papa
bless I like saying god bless - yeah
then people say Shalom everybody yeah
and then people also say now now
crickets yeah
I always joked that at this point
nobody's listening to so this one yeah
that's about meetup but it gets much
more loose and low pressure at this deep
in the show I come shock those filming
these cameras and there's nothing
there's not seriously people like to say
about me that that's a that now he's got
a clean butthole no I can take that to
the bank
are you gonna try the aloe pills and
report back to me I'm curious I'm scared
I just don't know that I want to [ __ ]
everything well just gonna keep saying
your corner I think you should just take
one but you don't like a Sunday I try to
keep it down so that's not that wasn't
me do it on like a Sunday morning
Saturday night doing on this set take
one on a Saturday night now Lomax and
that Sunday morning and then I want to
know Monday how it went okay dan can you
write it down what was it called a Lomax
brand I have an aloe pill there's a
couple different brands just like aloe
vera it's a low I think it's like pure
aloe I can't I couldn't tell you exactly
I'd have to look it up whatever it is it
makes you [ __ ] it makes you evacuate the
premises
I mean it sounds fun in a way is it fun
there is bi I think [ __ ] is orgasmic
I find do you like [ __ ] yeah
sometimes I'll take a fat [ __ ] that's so
fat I talked about this gratifying I
talked about this yesterday Obama and he
recoiled for me but I was like I kind of
get like gay dudes or I mean I get anal
sex because sometimes I'll take it [ __ ]
that's so gratifying and it's huge and
I'm and I actually really enjoy it so I
says if you feel that good coming out
there's got to be something about anal
sex no I think no I was like I get
Gators like whoa but that's really I was
like I could honey I really think I
could get [ __ ] in that way to be no
it's literally the opposite
it's good for coming out the inverse yes
the actual inverse I don't know she
probably doesn't want her baby to crawl
back in but yeah try it before you go
cuz it is time this is a very short
video it's one of my favorites you just
react to this
there we go it's only 30 seconds very
jumpy no no is it a dog that's gonna
come under no I don't like surprises
just I like no it's fun it just tell me
is it gonna be my [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
now that you know what it is watch
here's the best part about who's
[ __ ] said sorry I thought the dead
person Oh smell the stranger [ __ ] yeah
why because he turns him on I see in a
[ __ ] lab coat and why does he look
like Fred Armisen because he's problems
with first I thought it was Fred Armisen
and then I thought it was a dead guy
it's just a dude jerking off in a stall
like that you certain off lying down I
know I understand that no he was just
committing the memory way off on their
stomachs maybe some dudes hump their bed
huh like they if they're humping
something but you can't jerk off on your
stomach well so what's he doing why
isn't he I think he's just committing
the me right to the wank Bank the wank
Bank uh-huh is there a lot of [ __ ]
porn I don't even know I think that
dating certainly exists I don't know if
it's a popular genre mm-hmm German
apparently love ship porn that's what
they say
I've said I'm when I was in Germany I
saw and what we went into a pornography
store and they were selling scheisse
films they call it and I was at a
premium - they were selling for like 80
bucks because I having sex while
shooting or something like [ __ ] each
other's mouths and stuff okay
then that's actually it's super
expensive because I guess you got to pay
the girls a premium to [ __ ] in your
mouth yeah yeah I don't like yeah that
feels fair are you into pool porn like
basically we're feeding you you got to
pay for the meal
yeah all right should we wrap this up
Whitney Cummings has a new podcast out
right now called good for you it's
available it everywhere it's available
everywhere podcasts are available
including youtube we've got a tour
coming up do other people's podcast that
much when you did thios I was surprised
you know I don't know it doesn't like
doing you just don't like to
I don't like doing other people show
yeah why did you see OHS cuz I like yeah
and he's in the same building oh that's
helpful moved
oh he's using this no good okay that
helped and he's down the hall and and
also a Netflix special call great it's
not called great it is great can I take
this it's called can i touched on
netflix it's a saga it's a fantastic as
netflix so put it on and watch the
special got eesh mm-hm and what news
teams are open
I love [ __ ] pics I love I I'm
entertained by them I'm not upset by
dick pics but someone sent me a dick pic
I'm like all right delete a one-way
street I don't care I think it's funny
oh are you trying to get both spit
all right you know when you've been
talking so long you've like crushed on
your lip guys we're cut we've got crusts
on the lip it's been a long day it's
Friday
TGIF you know what I'm saying you know
we're getting the beyond burger right
have a great weekend you guys have a
fantastic time be good positivity and
love smile more you know we only talk
about smile more here no negative
thoughts here on the h3 nation only
happy thoughts that's nice of you oh
you're not wrong yeah no we're depressed
nation or cynical nation don't ride
elephants don't write up into your
[ __ ] [ __ ] out there you butt
and adopt only adopt don't buy right
don't go to circuit says don't go to the
girl shop don't go to SeaWorld don't buy
from breeder or cut off free oh look
what a sweetheart
no such thing as a hypoallergenic dog
yes there is he is that well he doesn't
shed that's true yeah he sells dander
yeah but I had dandruff yeah my is there
hypo gelatine saying now that there's
this such a labradoodle all that [ __ ] is
fake it's a scam don't fall for it they
don't shed that's true yeah don't not
shedding is one thing but they there's a
the hypoallergenic dog is of lives hi
sir he's my mom going about shredders
yes or buddy but I don't regret um he's
a purebred named Elton John Oh Fred
isn't even your key personality is such
a character sort of overcompensate with
bigger personalities
he's like a look he's a little human
being he such a diva
that's human eye oh god we have to go
home to get Theodore yes time okay we're
parents okay guys thank you everybody
hey guys
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]